I in that let me thank all the
organizers for setting this nice
workshop I'll be talking about
utilization balance for uniformly stable
algorithms and its joint work with young
bonds so let me start with sort of
describing the cast of characters in
this algorithms what am I even talking
about so so the basic setting we'll be
looking at is kind of a standard setting
of machine learning and statistics in
general with in which will have some
domain which will you know it like
capital Z you can think of those as
being labeled examples but this could be
arbitrary domain will have a data set
that will be noted by capital S which
consists of n points from the domain
will have some learning algorithm a
which Maps a data set to some model in
this set capital devil W and will have a
loss function that map's a model and the
point to some non-negative value
so given this notation we'll say that an
algorithm a is uniformly stable or has
uniform stability with parameter gamma
with respect to this loss function if
for all pairs of data sets which differ
just in a single element and arbitrary
point in the domain the loss of the
model output on the first of those data
sets on the point Z and minus the loss
of the algorithm output on their
neighboring data set on any point on
that same point Z differ by at most
gamma so basically the loss on any flaw
of the model output by the algorithm on
any point on arbitrary point that the
domain does not change much when you
replace a single point in a data set and
that holds for all data sets and again
for all point Z
no say-so here asses where we fix em and
we'll be fixed throughout the talk so in
some sense this gamma is a function of n
so this is a very strong sort of notion
of stability but well as we'll see there
are a number of very interesting
algorithms which have this property and
our goal will be to understand what kind
of generalization properties does this
notion imply yes everything the data set
you increase the loss won't you like
most gamma times and that's right and
we'll see how that sort of effects the
interplay between the range of the loss
and the stability parameter in a moment
so we'll be interested in understanding
how sort of how to derive the bounds on
translation error from stability
properties and let me just define this
formally we'll also have some
distribution of R ability distribution P
over the domain Z which will be also
fixed throughout this talk and we'll
think of our dataset as being sampled IG
from this from this distribution
so given this distribution we can define
the population loss for any model which
is just the expectation of this one of
the loss of a model on a point drawn
randomly from this distribution P and
for a given a data set we also can
define the empirical loss of a model
again just the average the mean of the
losses on the points in the data set and
the quantity of interest for us will be
the generalization error or gap which is
just the difference between the
population loss of the model output by
the algorithm on the data set s and the
empirical loss of the model of the data
set and the recent sort of why this is
non-trivial is because here again we are
using the same data set to produce the
the model and also using it to estimate
the loss everything is standard so far
so
our goal would be to say that if an
algorithm satisfy stability then we can
obtain some kind of bounds on this
variable deserve this
gap which depends on the data set s but
before we actually go in and I'll show
you the specific bounce we can prove let
me motivate why the question why one
would be even interested in
understanding a generalization for
uniformly stable algorithms so and
perhaps the most interesting motivation
comes from this simple and standard
setting of stochastic convex
optimization and let me restrict here
for the purposes of talk of some very
particular particularly simple setting
event in which the set of models will be
the unit ball in D dimensions and our
loss functions will be convex and my
lectures in this sort of in the in this
parameter W which is the model and the
goal is as usual is to minimize the
expected loss which is and will which is
just expectation with respect to the
this distribution of the loss and will
you know the the optimum by L star so of
course we all know how to solve this
problem there is this sort of the
classical algorithm it's the stochastic
gradient descent is where you'll just do
updates on gradient updates on every
single point and the sort of the
standard choice of crate will be some
like 1 over square root of N and you'll
take the average of the iterative and we
know that this the guarantee so for this
algorithms that are at this point
well-known is that basically what this
thing says is with high probability the
loss the true loss of the model that
will be output this will be no more than
the optimum press lost something on the
order of 1 over square square root n
times the log square root of log 1 over
Delta so this is nice and we know that
this is optimal the sort of the biggest
problem with this result is that in
practice there are many other algorithms
that are used for example what we use
patches we make multiple passes over
data with
use the even do full gradient descent in
some cases however the analysis that is
used to to obtain these guarantees
really relies on the fact that we'll be
using every point only once and once you
basically reuse data points we in most
cases we cannot say anything about
generalization of guarantees of the
algorithm we basically don't know how to
analyze the population a loss of the
algorithm and unless we make some
additional assumptions on the on the cap
on the models and the reason for this is
that basically out at our favorite tool
the use of uniform convergence no longer
works in this setting specifically if
you actually wanted so the standard way
we would do it we sort of prove
transition bounces that we separate we
minimize the empirical loss and then we
argue that on all on some set of models
or all all possible solutions empirical
loss is close to the population loss and
that's so-called uniform convergence
however in this setting to ensure
uniform convergence one needs basically
the error of the uniform convergence
scales as square root of D over N so it
basically one has to pay a factor D to
get above the sort of the bounds that we
have for stochastic gradient descent one
could maybe say that one doesn't really
need unify corners over all models that
maybe suffices to prove kind of only
this converges for the empirical
minimizer's but even for empirical
minimizer's one has to pay a factor in
there which scales with a with the
dimension D so as a result we cannot
obtain the same kind of bounds via where
standard approaches and this n has been
observed first by shall Schwarz and
others and has about specific bounds are
from my recent work so ok so given that
we cannot use the standard analysis what
can we do and it turns out that sort of
the best analysis the best general tool
that we have in this context to still
analyze algorithms like which we use
data points as we often do in practice
so what is
that's amidst it might have might have
that is okay there are some the specific
distributions for which there will be
empirical minimizer which has such a so
here here no I well I don't know how to
prove it with a square root I believe
that there should be one but I don't
know how to prove it I don't know if
anyone who does but for interim
convergence yes there is so so the most
general technique which still allows one
to to analyze algorithms ISKCON in this
context it turns out to be uniform
stability and by now there are two
examples the first one is kind of old
comes from the work of boost candle is a
ofin which shows the following if you
add which you add this kind of
regularizing why I would call it
stabilizing a strong term of two to the
empirical objective and then minimize it
either exactly or or with very small
error then the the solution of this will
be stable specifically for when when
this again at this setting where
everything is where in the unit ball and
convex and everything is convex one
Lipschitz the will get our stability
parameter will be something like 1 over
lambda n and but introduction of this
sort of additional term also introduces
error so will so now the minimization of
the original objective will be not exact
but within lambda over 2 so in order to
so one what basically have to trade off
somehow the error and the stability when
using this this approach so and another
another uniformly stable algorithm for
for this setting has been given in a
work of hard draft and singer who showed
that basically gradient step on small
gradient steps are on smooth losses
basically do are stable and are very
instantiate their result so for example
one way to instantiate it is to show
that if you perform full gradient
achieve steps of full gradient with say
rate of 1 over over square root of T
then the resulting algorithm first of
all will have uniform stability with
some like square root T over N and will
minimize of course sort of the more
steps you make the less stable you are
and the more steps you make the better
you optimize the empirical objective so
again you'll get a trade-off between the
how well you optimize and and the
stability parameter and the sort of the
reason why this trade-off is important
is it at the end of the day we of course
want to upper bound the generalization
the true loss and the error of the on
the true loss will be sort of the sum of
error hours of optimality on the
empirical loss plus something which
depends on the stability there and and
sort of there our bound will be we'll
need to convert our bound our stability
bound organization bound and the better
would and the better we can do that the
better we can map our stability to
generation error the better guarantees
will obtain for these algorithms and
indeed all known unknown duration bounds
releases rely on answer of this
generation but for uniformly stable
algorithms so let me now but we show
what's known about those so us so for
this purposes will restrict the loss to
have ranges 0 1 and in this case one can
think of uniform of a stability
parameter as being in the range of 1
over N to 1 indeed if sort of it doesn't
make sense to think about stability
being less than 1 over N the range of
the loss otherwise you're not even using
the whole range of your function and
sort of if you want to think of a some
specific value of stability you should
think of
the most interesting value for the
purpose of analysis we won over square
root of n that's the stability that
we'll have for our algorithms and the
question is what kind of generation
bounds we can get for this value of
stability so a result that has been
known for now forty years is that the
expectation of the generation error is
at most when the equation over all data
sets draw an ID from P to the N is at
most gamma so the value is small in
expectation but that doesn't sort of
allow us to say anything almost anything
even we can't we cannot convert it into
a low probability statement about how
close it actually isn't a specific data
set the reason for this say is that this
value can be negative as opposed to we
cannot even apply Markov inequality to
say that with some constant probability
it's at least some multiple of gamma so
and of course we would like to say
something stronger about generation
error and that's kind of the reason why
scale is they have introduced this
notion of universe debility and what
they have proved is that with
probability at most Delta maybe it
probably at least 1 over Delta the
transition error is less than gamma
times square root of n so it's a high
probability statement but unfortunately
you have to pay a factor of squirrel and
in the in the rate and what this implies
at least for our purposes that it's we
cannot be used for the interesting range
of parameters where the stability is 1
over square root of n so that which
brings into to our result and hours off
can be actually it's even exactly the
same setting we prove that the same
result but now instead of gamma times
squirrel and
we proved abound with basically square
root of gamma and it's kind of easy to
see that in this range of parameters it
always dominates the previous bound if
you want to see it kind of pictorially
okay so this is for N equals to 100 and
that's the range of the parameter that
we are interested in a properly 1 over
square root of n the previous bound
become already vacuous at this point we
get a bound that is at least give
something meaningful for for all for all
values of stability parameter gamma so
one natural question of course is this
even the best bound that one can prove
for transition and I actually think we
have a give evidence that it's not the
best bound and actually show which we
look at this by looking at the second
moment observation error we prove that
the second moment is at most gamma
squared plus one over N which roughly
think of it corresponds to the rate of
gamma plus 1 over square root of n so
there is no once there is no square root
of gamma it's just gamma plus but there
has to be some kind of floor of 1 over
square root of N and it's actually easy
to see that this is a typed result this
the best one can hope and from this
result one can already get some kind of
low probability generation results with
the optimal rate by using the standard
champion inequality you'll get this rate
of gamma plus 1 over square root of n
for where the worst dependence on Delta
in this case so again it's easy to see
that you have to pay pleased gamma if
you for stability and 1 over square root
of n is you get even for a fixed
function that is does not depend on the
data
why is this worse I mean okay well we
would like to ideally would like we
would like to get the square root of log
1 over Delta Y because we will only
prove this bound for the second moment
it's optimal so again and again that
second on that also has been studied for
almost 40 years and the best previous
bound was gamma plus 1 over N so they
didn't get the gamma square in fact sort
of the what was known for the second
moment is what we now prove for them
with high probability and here is again
pictorial comparison this is the
previous bound and that's our bound and
again in the interesting regime of
setting of parameters with roughly 1
over square n square root of n we get
stability with the rate of 1 over square
root of n whereas the previous bound
basically gets 1 over 4th root of n ok
so that's all that I want to say about
the statement of the result itself let
me know if there are questions so far so
let me now briefly mention the the
implication of this for the stochastic
romo stochastic convex optimization for
the algorithms that I've described it's
kind of easy to see that one gets for
both of those algorithms one gets this
kind of low probability generation
results worth basically with the rate 1
over square root of n but some kind of
polynomial dependents on Delta if one
wants actually have once for very small
values of Delta it makes sense to go to
the high probability results but they're
the sort of the rate that one would get
this would be suboptimal n to the one
third although again at least a no
longer vacuous unlike previous result
and so so basically one gets a stronger
generation results in in this setting
and let me mention one more application
which is kind of from a different domain
and also like some other work of mine
and it comes from the context of
so-called differentially private
prediction and these are algorithms
I skip the motivation but these are
basically algorithms randomized
algorithm says that whose predictions
are differentially private in the
following sense if you replace one
element in the data set the distribution
over the distribution over labels for
any for any point for any point on which
you predict the model you predict will
will not change by my specific lis it
will satisfy the the standard definition
different of different so privacy that
sort of infinity divergence between the
prediction of a model on point X when
given data set s and the same prediction
on the same point when given the
neighboring data set the divergence in
these distributions infinity or divorce
will be at most Epsilon and it's easy to
see that this definition if the
algorithm says Phi this definition then
for any loss function over labels the
expected loss will have uniform
stability I mean it's kind of very
similar definition here it's for
distribution but but it implies that
that the expected loss will be stable
and this means that that basically gives
allows us to use this result on
generalization to obtain a stronger
duration bound for algorithms which
satisfy this property and there's an eye
on what the mission this application is
that also shows that this kind of
framework of uniformly stable algorithms
can be first of all used in the context
of classification by looking so normally
a zero one loss would not be stable
because it can only have two values 0
and 1 and these are not sale but if you
look at randomized algorithms you can
now look at the expected loss and there
you can talk about stability but of
course will be stability for the
expected loss and secondly even though
even though in the context of
classification we do have uniform
convergence whenever things are learn
about we might for various reasons want
to use algorithms other
the empirical risk minimize there are
other elderts that we might want to
analyze and this framework and that's
executor of the situation we had in this
context we had a different a new
algorithm for which one could not apply
uniform convergence bounds but we were
able to analyze it using this framework
even though engagements yeah
even though normally one would have a
uniform convergence result in this
setting yes are you see the loss is
strongly convex on this result so this
this is no no no no strong convexity
here so we get the same bounds for both
of the uniform stability results that I
have mentioned one of them you adds a
strongly convex term to make it stable
the other assumes a little bit of
smoothness so both have additional some
additional so the first one doesn't have
any assumptions but it adds a strongly
convex secure Arizer the second one does
have a relatively weak assumption on
smoothness so that's all that I want to
say about the results themselves
let me now actually go to proofs so in
order to make the proof actually a
little easier to describe we'll go to
even more general setting which will
refer to as data dependent functions and
data dependent fashion is basically any
function which takes as a data set in a
single point and outputs a real value
you can think of previously our data
dependent function was the loss of the
model output on the data set S on Point
C but could be any function which
depends on the data set and also a point
and we can define for this kind of data
dependent functions we can define
uniform stability in exactly the same
way so now basically it again for any
pair of bases which differ in a single
point and any value of the second
parameter the values are with an gamma
so if you think of
so so basically if you think of the
function which is output on any data set
when you change the data set the
function changes but most gamma in
infinity-norm so these are the functions
which are output on neighboring data
sets are closed within this parameter I
would like to prove something about the
generation error for such data dependent
functions where again generalization
error would be the expectation of the of
this function output on s on acquaint on
from this distribution - the same
expectation of the same function output
on s when we averaged on the same data
set make sense so if not now like to
prove something in this slightly more
general context and before going to our
proof as a warm-up let me briefly review
that sort of the proofs of the of the
simpler results the well-known results
that I have mentioned so first well show
that the expectation of regeneration
error is at most um and that's and
that's actually very simple so let's
look at the first look at the
expectation of the empirical error which
is just the expectation of the of the
value of the function on a point a
chosen randomly from the data set for
each such each each such evaluation we
know that stability allows us to upper
bounded by the value of the same
function when we replace the point at
position I with some other point so you
can replace the point and we sort of
using the same point which is in the
data set we can replace it with a
different point and add that most gamma
now we can so because this is true for
any replacement with point Z this is
also true when we replace the point at
position i with a point z drawn randomly
from the same distribution
so now just plugging this expression
back into the expectation
we'll obtain that that the simple
expectation of the empirical value is
upper bounded by the expectation of this
value with the replaced point but the
point which is with which replaces
chosen independently plus gamma if we
look carefully at the sort of the
parameters of this function they're all
independent so these are because we
replaced point Zi with some random and
independent point these n plus 1 points
used here are all completely independent
they're all distributed as basically SP
to the n plus 1 we can really just
rename them as the data set s and Z
which just which basically gives us that
this world that our Bao allow the
stopper bound this empirical mean using
the population value of of the same of
the same function this is kind of a the
most basic and standard trick in M
converting stability to generalization
bounds so now that we see that the
expectation is small let's very quickly
see why one can obtain some kind of high
probability bounds so to get sort of a
simple way to obtain high probability
generation about is to observe that this
function that this generation gap or
generation error as a function of data
set s has bound the differences because
when you change just data set from s to
s Prime the this generation error can
change by at most two gamma plus 1 over
N and the reason this again it's very
simple so generation gap has two parts
has been pericle has the true mean which
when we replace the data set because the
function changes in infinity norm BiCMOS
gamma it's true min can also change by
most gamma if we look at the empirical
part again at there the change of the
data set requires both the function
and the points on which this function is
evaluated so we have to pay gamma for
the change of the function and also
because we replace one of the points
we'll have to pay at most one over m
when we replace one of the points and
that's because the range of the function
is of the losses most zero one so
replacing a single point can change it
in the mean can change by the most one
over n so only no this implies that
generation error can change by at most
two gamma plus one over N so we can just
apply the standard Mag McDermott's
inequality to get that the probability
that this generation error is greater
equal than its mean plus this whatever
this this bound the difference times
roughly square root n log 1 over Delta
is it most Delta and we know that the
mean is small the mean is just at most
gamma so we get the result of Bousquet
and Elysees if we are the simple
analysis and then again you can see it
where exactly the square root and a
factors come from now let's get to our
proof and it's sort of a first to let me
mention that it's based on ideas that
have been developed in the context of
analyzing duration properties of
differential privacy that were first
done in a context of adaptive data
analysis by me some stammer and silly
stammer Nissim stammer Smith thank and
Ullman and the technique sort of based
on the following simple observation it's
much easier to to use this kind of
stability to use it's much easier to use
this stability when analyzing the
expected value of generalization error
therefore it as a first step these
techniques use the following lemma it's
a very simple kind of exercise and
probability if you for any let we denote
by Q any probability distribution over
reals then for any such distribution a
probability that the value will be
greater equal than twice the expectation
of the maximum over m independent copies
of the same random variable is it most
roughly one over m so it's basically
says that the probability that the
roughly the expectation of the maximum m
independent copies if is roughly 1 over
m percentile just doesn't say anything
else but but the nice thing here is that
now we can upper bound the sort of the
the tail probability by analyzing the
expectation of the variable that we are
interested in a creation of the maximum
over m over m independent copies plus 0
m uh make sense so how would what would
we need to use to use this for the
proper result we would need to basically
create m independent copies of our
generation error and to do this we'll
draw not just a single data set will
draw m independent data sets as one for
s m4 m which is roughly again 1 over
delta and our goal will be to bound the
expectation of the maximum of these
generation errors on on each on these m
data sets well there needs to be 0 but
I'll remove it just to make it a little
cleaner so how can one bound let's try
to bound this expectation of the maximum
generation error so we can first look at
the empirical part of this generation
error which is again which is which
would be equal to expectation over the
empirical value of the function on the
data set L where L is there the the
index where the generation error is the
largest the maximum of degeneration
errors and let's do our standard trick
of replacing
the basic level V is greater than the
expectation of the maximum so this is
this is in so this is all inside the
probability over m independent copies
it's anyway so we were okay so we would
like to understand how close the
empirical mean on the on the partition
with the largest generation error is how
close it is to the true mean of this
function when we choose the tradition
with the largest generation error and
would like to do it by using the our
favorite trick where we replace the one
of the points within the data set with a
fresh point so and if we do it we know
that like we replace one of the points
in the data set with a fresh point we
know that the empirical mean will not
change by much that's sort of what
stability gives us the problem however
the once we change a single point in the
data set the data set with a larger
generation error might also change might
jump to a completely different data set
so as a result this quantity is not
stable and we cannot just do the same
trick basically the problem is that okay
so we cannot argue about closeness of
these two quantities because the maximum
is not stable so how will we solve it
actually obvious we'll want to stabilize
the maximum and to do this we'll do it
kind of we are now sort of standard
exponential mechanist which is just a
kind of exponential sapling first
introduced in this context they
introduced by McSherry and tavar in 2007
and basically what it does it samples
instead of outputting just the maximum
it samples an index randomly with
probability proportional to e to the
some alpha which is the some parameters
we'll choose later x is that value times
the value so in this case the value will
be the
generation error at partition or data
set with index J so what do we know
about this this kind of way to pick the
largest element or an element we know
that it's stable I mean in fact it's
known that it's stable in a very strong
senses differentially private which
means that whenever we replace any of
the data points here we know that the
value of this the value of generation
error changes by at most two gamma plus
one over N which we've proven that in
our warm-up set exercise plus this
factor alpha I'm it's easy to see that
the probability of outputting any index
J can change by can change but most
eetu this to the power of this parameter
and if we just plug it into sort of the
same trick we'll now again looking now
we can look at the expectation of the
empirical value of the algorithm while
choosing the index using this
exponential sampling we'll again we'll
pay the I'll have to pay this factor of
e to the e to this parameter minus one
because of the change in the probability
the probability of outputting every
index can change by at most this value
plus will pay gamma as before we just
just for the change in value and again
the important part that is on this side
will obtain the expectation of the over
the datasets the choice of the the
choice of the index using this
exponential sampling of the true mean of
the function so basically after
stabilizing the maximum we can now
relate the empirical to the true value
and the other important properties that
we need is that this expansion sampling
is actually close to the true or the
maximum and that's just basically comes
from relatively easy to perfect that it
kind of implements softmax so the
spectating I mean again it holds in
general for any values but in this case
for for our generation error the
expected expected value of this
generation where error when we pick the
ticket using this exponential sampling
is at least the actual maximum plus 1 M
over alpha so now okay so we know that
it's close to the true maximum and and
and we can also for for this soft Maxima
or stable maximum we can bound the this
step from empirical two to the
population value just playing this
together we obtain that again the
expectation of the maximum over m
independent of this generation error
over m all the importance is upper bound
by this lon M over alpha from the
approximate maximum plus this factor
from the from the step to generation
error now by just picking the right
alpha which in this case is just lon M
over gamma plus one over n we get that
this value it's a again it's easy to see
the square root of gamma plus 1 over n
times 1 1 over Delta and if you recall
this is the value that we would like to
plug in into the right side of our hyper
ability bound and that's exactly the
value that we were aiming for so we get
instead of squirrel 10 times gamma we'll
get the square root of gamma plus 1 over
N times times 1 1 over Delta ya and
that's it that's basically the proof
again we just stabilized the maximum and
get a proof of the concentration quality
let me know if there are any questions
maybe too fast for this talk but it's
really all the ideas are there I mean we
also have some nice tricks to prove
their second bound on the second moment
but those are a little more technical
and harder to make interesting in a talk
so let me basically conclude so as I
wanted to show you that we now have a
slightly better understanding of uniform
stability and we perhaps most
interesting we have a new technique to
prove bounds about it
there are many sort of open problems in
this area but sort of the most obvious
here is that we still have a a gap
between upper and lower bounds for high
probability in our high probability
statement so we don't really know the
answer and n cervan it would be kind of
interesting to understand how which of
these high probability generation bounds
can be obtained under Weekender notions
of stability not just uniform but maybe
some bounds and moments and so on by the
repetition
[Music]
so no so so the setting that I described
was general not just binary prediction
and result is this difference between
uniform convergence is is not for you
and it's not for the binary prediction
it's for general stochastic convex
optimization which which is more general
yeah if we know that we're solving a
binary classification via Aram then
we're good and for some other settings
like square regression with squared loss
will not in general
okay thank you
[Applause]